[Music]
SKT went through probably one of the
roughest offseason they have ever went
through they lost
Goma Khan and Clinton met me ded yo yo
sup want a policy come here Teddy don't
wanna a phony I'll play my effort breeds
the hook and then can sit there and grab
but it's just the kill now Teddy [ __ ]
mad in the backline looking for more
gets himself a lifeline passive nails
the Quadra kill Boulevard I said that is
going to fill it t1 are your lck
straight 2020 champions
faker made it back to the top of Korea
in 2019 armed with the new super team
composed of some of the region's best
players t1 dominated the 2019 lck season
winning both the spring and summer
splits but all of that success wasn't
enough to keep the t1 dream team
together following a disappointing
worlds run that ended in the semi-finals
con include both left t1 for new homes
and though he hadn't been a starting
support for quite a while Matta
eventually left the team as well even
coach kkoma who'd been with faker since
his debut 7 years ago left the team to
join the LPL t1 was forced to rebuild
again with faker left to lead this new
young squad as the oldest player on the
team
seguramente yo-yo so Ponte season you
know grande said oh my season is jumping
on equal to positive or negative
people at Hyundai MK heroin what
America's all mana Khemia
these new players had huge shoes to fill
coach Kim Cana and cuz we're joining the
back-to-back l/c k champions and t1 fans
did not want to see that streak and now
I'm condoms in there I just thought I
thought I've got your number money our
cool they go to our wall circus of
course our estas gun taken unit put on
long is a piece of well sounds like a
total column Bonham and wondering that's
me today on air and despite an
underwhelming showing at the Casper Cup
these new additions showed up when the
spring season kicked off breaker around
at the make of rain where is the car -
oh I guess they're thinking that she's
not needed yet flash face breaker there
from fly is Teddy still s flash gets
over the wall with it and this is still
going a trench line tool and there's
Epis going to give Baker that kill a
double now make that three as cuz joins
in the party for the one but alongside
the early success came growing paint a
breakup will topple t1
normative our lives
there's a critic that fundamentally
known you job do going on just a button
there hey babe untie right now so so
cool
I told if I managed whirlpool go get
your girl well no one ever helped me
they were still a new team and their
competition is strong
t1 finished the regular season in second
place with an impressive 14 inform match
record but there was still one team
ahead of them a super team that everyone
had their eyes on 13 to 0 in Fertile
sole double barren that's pop game my
friend perfect game comes in Gen Z
you're gonna take the two one Jen G's
new star-studded lineup featured BDD the
only mid laner ever to beat faker in an
lck final is going to say good night to
the king of the midlane the Nexus bold
and your new champions of the LC cash
okay man despite a rough 2019 BDD
returned to his old championship formed
this year and was named league MVP and
first-team all-pro mid laner / faker
to the back line will fit me today to
see what he can actually get done in
this fight there it is the old lands on
two one
he grabs three kills and remember [ __ ] t
ones former star jungler well now he's
on BD DS side joining Genji in the off
season from the hadith Mud Hens in
deliberate until they go get to ethology
will attend J to cut down on Tim well
[Music]
Maxim Tokarev and Annika toy do struggle
while Genji might have been higher in
the standings t1 went undefeated against
this new super team in the regular
season a record
faker wasn't about to give up in the
funds brought up but that awardee did
not expect to see cozier as over the
wall goes cuz due to have the damage the
flash forward and and there it is first
blood and he immediately give it to cuz
when he's just so squishy and he's gonna
be first down in the bag now ruler
having five his life was there in the
front line and this is absolute disaster
for Genji and the bombs will come down
get busted the back line as now invert
lining it up in the front and it comes
buzz once again he is going to go down
but he sets up the hill full of air guys
and that is going to do it t1 are your
lck spring 2020 champions and another
3-0 victory in the world as t1
dominating their opponents gentie it was
not close t1 demolished Genji in the
files and faker got to exact some sweet
revenge on his former teammate and his
mid lane rival but faker couldn't do it
alone his teammates both old and new
stepped up when it mattered most cuz
even earned Finals MVP for the absolute
clinic he pulled on the player he
replaced faker may have lost his 2019
super team but he's more than made up
for it with a new team of young rising
stars he now leads as the oldest mid
laner to win the lck waker your ninth
title in lck and this is the second time
you get this back-to-back-to-back title
in lck and the oldest mid laner to win
lck you've accomplished a lot of history
so the fact that they owe this meal and
there to win the title it doesn't really
feel real real and i really wanted to
get this win today
having conquered korea again fakers eyes
are set on accomplishing something he
failed to do with his old super team a
goal he hasn't accomplished since 2016
[Music]
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring that notification bell for unique
bite-sized videos you will find anywhere
else hit up our Instagram Twitter and
Facebook pages